[Música]
a
desde el descongelamiento cataluña vio
crecer su población o rural ya que
muchas familias quisieran irse de las
ciudades y todas lo explican por el
mismo motivo pues el confinamiento
español que recordamos fue de los más
duros de europa ya que los adultos sólo
podían salir para con oír al médico
mientras que los niños estuvieron casi
dos meses sin salir de sus casas
así pues frente a esta fuerte demanda
nación en varias plataformas que luchan
contra la despoblación jugar y que haga
y pues ponen en contacto a familias que
buscan pueblos y a pueblos que buscan a
trabajadores pero este éxodo urbano
también plantea nuevos retos para los
alcaldes de estos pueblos quienes tienen
que ampliar sus infraestructuras como en
las escuelas o el abastecimiento de agua
pero todos lo hacen felices dicen para
los que vuelven a ver
sus pueblos llenos de vida
[Música]
la pandemia de coronavirus está
generando un fenómeno de éxodo urbano en
italia por miedo al contagio miles de
personas están abandonando las grandes
ciudades aprovechando de la posibilidad
de trabajar a distancia desde pequeños
pueblos o inclusive desde el campo la
consecuencia es que las grandes
metrópolis del norte del país están
desocupando de sus trabajadores estima
que la ciudad de milán capital de la
región de lombardía ha perdido más de
12.000 habitantes desde el mes de
febrero de este año y paralelamente el
sur del país ha iniciado a ver regresar
una nueva población de trabajadores a
distancia a un fenómeno que está
poniendo en jaque el concepto mismo de
las aglomeraciones urbanas y está
cambiando los equilibrios entre el norte
y el sur del país aquí en italia
[Música]
en california especialmente en grandes
ciudades como san francisco y los
ángeles parece ser que la pandemia está
exacerbando una tendencia que ya se veía
desde hacía unos dos o tres años la la
mudanza de la clase media a estados oa
zonas rurales que sean más económicas
ante los precios imposibles del nivel de
vida en esta zona ahora mismo según
concluyen varias empresas de mudanzas
que son los principales datos que se
tienen hasta ahora sobre este éxodo
desde la pandemia desde los meses de
mayo a junio hasta ahora se han
triplicado el número de mudanzas sobre
todo en la zona de san francisco y
silicon valley una parte bueno buena
parte de la razón por la que la mayor
parte de la gente se podría haber estado
viendo desde mayo hasta ahora cuando se
relajaron las las reglas por el
coronavirus podría ser principalmente
que las grandes empresas tecnológicas
han permitido a la mayor parte de sus
empleados trabajar indefinidamente desde
casa manteniendo el sueldo
[Música]